[Musica]
che dire Buongiorno e grazie a tutti
quanti per essere qui intanto da
pisognese sono estremamente felice e
orgoglioso di poter partecipare a un
evento come questo in un luogo così
bello come la nostra Santa Maria della
Neve conosciuta ai più come la Cappella
Sistina dei poveri a 300 metri dove sono
cresciuto sostanzialmente che poi
è un nomignolo un po' ingiusto perché
questo complesso pittorico è ricchissimo
è molto all'avanguardia rispetto alla
tradizionale pittura rinascimentale
Michelangelo l'esca
e per questo è stato oggetto di studio
da parte di moltissimi studiosi e
critici provenienti da tutta Italia e
dal mondo intero
ci sarebbe poi molto da dire in
proposito non basterebbe un quarto d'ora
non basterebbe una giornata intera per
cercare di trovare nelle espressionismo
storico del Romanino un significato
proprio però posso solo dire e posso
solo aggiungere che questa chiesa di
povero Non ha assolutamente niente Per
quanto riguarda invece il mio tema è
fondamentale sapere che esattamente qui
di fuori dietro questo portale in
arenaria che adesso è coperto
c'è un cammino una strada la nostra
Antica via Valeriana che oggi È percorsa
da centinaia da migliaia di camminatori
ogni anno ma
E fa parte del della rete
escursionistica del turismo lento
italiano e ricalca il tracciato di una
vecchia strada romana la via Valeriana
collegava
la nostra Brescia con il passo del
Tonale il confine naturale con il
Trentino Alto Adige che in tempi più
remoti è stata percorsa a piedi o a
cavallo da parte di chi per spostarsi
aveva solo la forza delle proprie gambe
e del proprio cuore
Ma com'è che il viaggio centra con
l'evoluzione si starà chiedendo qualcuno
suppongo
oggi chi viaggia lo fa specialmente per
piacere lo diamo per scontato per
egoistico piacere diciamo considerato
che è diventato incredibilmente facile
spostarsi Grazie ai mezzi grazie alla
tecnologia grazie ai trasporti a basso
costo all'aereo 19,99 che penso che per
un po' non vedremo più
lo diamo per scontato e però ci
dimentichiamo che fino a poco tempo fa
lo spostamento era così complicato così
difficile da richiedere anche
lunghissime percorrenze a piedi per
distanze che oggi noi consideriamo brevi
una volta ci si spostava solo per
costrizione per Fede per sopravvivenza e
per estrema necessità perché quello che
oggi noi consideriamo un mero svago una
volta era un grande grande sacrificio
Anche perché non sempre si tornava
indietro non tutti tornavano a casa
basti pensare per fare un paragone
all'epoca dei grandi pellegrinaggi a
quanti europei sono migrati e sono
partiti per la Terra santa all'epoca di
re baldovino e a quanti poi sono
scappati tornando seni indietro dopo
l'assedio di Gerusalemme e la presa di
San Giovanni d'Acri
però per fare un esempio un po' più
vicino a noi io attingerei a una nostra
vecchia storia pisognese che mi
appartiene mi avvicina di più il mio
trisavolo il mio antenato il primo
Romano di Pisogne arrivo Qui molto tempo
fa non si sa esattamente quando e arrivo
da chissà dove
noi abbiamo sempre supposto che
arrivasse dal sud Italia però
Considerato che non esistono documenti
non possiamo essere certi e con se aveva
poco o niente Aveva due figli e aveva un
carretto con il quale si spostava e sul
quale trasportava i pochi attrezzi e le
poche cose i pochi bagagli che aveva con
sé lo stretto necessario per vivere e
per lavorare
di mestiere era un artista diciamo lui
facevo lo scultore faceva l'intagliatore
ha costruito i primi mobili Ma la sua
specialità era la costruzione e la
riparazione delle ruote dei carri che
all'epoca era una specialità in legno
naturalmente e questo non era da tutti e
questo forse basta per capire quanto il
nostro mondo sia cambiato nell'arco di
pochissimi anni grazie soprattutto allo
spostamento allo spostamento di poche e
di tante persone uno dei primi grandi
viaggi di piacere invece è stato fatto
subito dopo L'invenzione dell'automobile
giusto per citare una persona a noi
vicina dal momento in cui l'uomo ha
l'automobile e gli può fare qualsiasi
cosa e andare ovunque vuole così nel
1907 è stato indetto un raid
automobilistico è sostanzialmente una
gara solo lunghissima percorrenza dove a
vincere è la resistenza dell'equipaggio
e del mezzo che ha portato cinque
equipaggi europei tra cui uno italiano a
percorrere 16.000 km la distanza tra
Pechino e Parigi in 60 giorni di tempo e
furono proprio i nostri esploratori
italiani il principe Scipione Borghese
il pilota Ettore Guzzardi e il
giornalista Luigi Barzini ad avere la
meglio arrivarono dopo 60 giorni di
lunghissimo viaggio a Parigi
attraversando dei luoghi in cui l'auto
non era ancora arrivata in cui non
esistevano mappe in cui non esistevano
figuriamoci le strade
però a questo punto è bene fare una
distinzione per non confondere le idee
bisogna che ci poniamo subito questa
domanda prima di poter andare avanti Che
differenza c'è Oggi tra il viaggio e la
vacanza
si può rispondere con alcuni esempi
pratici senza scadere nella filosofia
spiccia da bar Chi va in vacanza di
solito sceglie una valigia una valigia
grande e grossa pesante che si fa fatica
a portare in giro che ti fanno storie
all'imbarco per l'aereo che si disfa
all'arrivo e si rifà quando è il momento
di tornare a casa chi viaggia invece usa
lo zaino
Chi va in vacanza tendenzialmente
Prenota un alloggio comodo dopo averne
valutati diversi dopo aver spulciato
tutte le recensioni possibili
immaginabili cercando di capire qual è
il letto più comodo e dove c'è l'aria
condizionata eccetera eccetera
predilige il relax e letti comodi chi
viaggia invece si adatta ad ogni
situazione infine quando siamo in
vacanza tendiamo a fare base in un luogo
o poco più magari in due andiamo a
muoverci a ragnatela sul territorio
circostante a seconda di quelli che sono
i nostri interessi a seconda di quello
che vogliamo visitare il viaggiatore
invece si sposta giorno dopo giorno e
ricerca attraverso lo spostamento la
propria evoluzione interiore
possiamo dire a questo punto che il
viaggio sia stato e che sia tutt'oggi il
motore stesso dell'evoluzione ma solo se
viene fatto nel modo giusto con criterio
e nel modo più consapevole come detto
prima oggi è diventato facilissimo
spostarsi ed è diventato alla portata di
tutti grazie ai trasporti a basso costo
Come si è detto prima e purtroppo a
causa della Mole sempre più crescente di
viaggiatori e scriteriati attenti più a
stare al passo con i tempi alla
tecnologia e alle comodità a farsi il
selfie perfetto nel posto più blasonato
andare in posti di moda si tende sempre
di meno a cercare delle esperienze
interiori che possano completare noi
stessi e progredire così nella nostra
crescita nella nostra evoluzione
Ma come si può evolvere viaggiando
sembra quasi una cosa strana da dire
per evolvere viaggiando è necessaria una
combinazione di elementi una ricetta con
tre semplici ingredienti per fare un
viaggio alla ricerca dell'evoluzione
interiore
per evolversi viaggiando bisogna andare
da soli
e a piedi aggiungerei
Trovate le vostre forze sfidate voi
stessi
scoprite i vostri limiti e superateli
E cosa più importante
immedesimatevi nei viaggiatori di un
tempo per ritrovare così le vostre
radici
una delle esperienze più belle che ho
fatto io È stata proprio percorrere la
via Francigena a piedi tra Canterbury
Roma dall'Inghilterra all'Italia in 70
giorni di viaggio a piedi
è stato il mio primissimo lungo viaggio
in un momento in cui avevo bisogno di
stare da solo di pensare ai fatti miei e
di scattare valanghe di fotografie è
stata una cura e mi è servito moltissimo
ed è stato un viatico per moltissimi
progetti che ho portato a termine e sui
quali sto ancora lavorando ho scritto la
mia prima pubblicazione ho iniziato a
scrivere per delle riviste Ho fatto
delle mostre fotografiche dove
attraverso le immagini racconto la mia
esperienza e prossimamente ne racconterò
molte altre
per evolvere viaggiando bisogna cercare
un contatto con la natura che è l'unica
vera cura contro la pressione della
modernità
contro il caos del mondo moderno e
isolatevi nella Quiete nella pace di un
campo di grano dormite in tenda
ascoltate i rumori della notte e non
avete paura
Respirate l'aria fresca di una vetta
dopo averla scalata dormite in tenda di
nuovo sudate e camminate e sporcatevi
fino a puzzare E poi lavatevi nel primo
lago nel primo fiume che trovate
altrimenti non lavatevi
vedete voi
terzo ingrediente che è forse il più
importante di tutti per evolvere
viaggiando è necessario avere una meta
perché darsi un obiettivo e raggiungerlo
è molto più soddisfacente più appagante
e più bello di qualsiasi giro a caso
percorrete la via Valeriana qui di fuori
a pochi passi da casa nostra o il
sentiero numero uno l'alta via
dell'adamello
in Irlanda Viaggiate molto fino in
Cappadocia restaurate la vecchia Panda
del nonno e percorrete la via della seta
fino a Samarcanda
intraprendete il pellegrinaggio in terra
santa
L'anno scorso sono arrivato a
Gerusalemme dopo una lunga lunga
scarpinata durata a quattro mesi non è
stata una semplice Passeggiata del tipo
io vado e torno tra 4 mesi è stato un
sogno nel cassetto che ho coltivato con
costanza e con pazienza ogni giorno dei
miei 30 anni è stata dura è stata
veramente dura Ho rischiato ma alla fine
è fin troppo riduttivo dire che alla
fine fosse soddisfatto e anche questa
storia presto tardi verrà raccontata
perché in questo mondo di turismo
massificato per evolversi Bisogna
tornare ad essere viaggiatori ad essere
persone in cammino a cercare e trovare
noi stessi lontano dai comfort Borghesi
e in ordine con la natura stessa per
evolvere viaggiando dobbiamo tornare ad
essere scopritori di mondi dobbiamo
tornare ad essere contemplatori di
tradizione avventurieri e navigatori in
cerca di emozioni perché il viaggio
anzitutto è un atto di libertà Grazie
[Applauso]